le conseil général de la réunion vous
présente lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais
dans notre société les personnes
porteuses de handicap sont nombreuses
mais pour autant elle ne sont pas
suffisamment reconnus et ne sont pas
suffisamment prises en charge
entre manque d'infrastructures et
parfois manque de considération
nous ne laissons que peu de place à ces
personnes en difficulté alors quels sont
les différents moyens mis en place pour
aider ces personnes
comment sensibiliser et éveiller les
consciences face à ce problème de
société
on en parle maintenant dans l'es1
sociale
parmi les dispositifs que le conseil
général met en oeuvre aux finances
figure les établissements médico sociaux
gros plan sur la maison henri lafay où
les résidents peuvent s'épanouir en
pratiquant diverses activités
artistiques la maison henri lafay est un
établissement qui accueille sous un même
toit un foyer d'accueil occupationnel et
un foyer d'accueil médicalisé
c'est à dire que l'on peut venir s'aérer
l'esprit tout en recevant le traitement
prescrit par son médecin
il s'agit d'une prise en charge qui se
fait de façon générale pour tous les
résidents tout en sachant que certains
résidants nécessitent des prises en
charge médicalisée particulière qu'il ne
s'agit donc pas d'un centre de soins
mais d'un centre où chacun peut être
accompagnée et s'amuser tout en recevant
le traitement prescrit le projet de la
maison il a fait repose sur un concept
en est hors les murs en les murs parce
que nous résidents au besoin d'avoir ses
murs ils ont besoin d'être rassurés de
vivre dans un environnement qui leur
permet de ne pas craindre l'agression
extérieure et en même temps hors les
murs puisqu'il ya nécessité dans leur
position de citoyens d'aller chercher
dans la cité l'ensemble tout ce que
l'établissement ne peut pas leur
procurer cet accompagnement sur le volet
artistique se fait toujours en binôme
il ya toujours un artiste invité et un
éducateur qui suit un groupe qui est qui
met en oeuvre justement une pratique
artistique
encore une fois pour mettre en avant
pour développer des potentiels mais des
potentiels qui sont voulus par la
personne puisque la personne elle est
concernée par cette prise en charge
elle n'est pas simplement soigner elle
est par l epa patiente au sens
d'attendre que les choses se fassent
elle est actrice de son projet la maison
henri lafay est un lieu stable et
rassurant pour ces personnes fragilisées
par la vie
emilie a trouvé à la maison henri lafay
un nouveau lieu de vie où elle
s'épanouit complètement sans pour autant
être dans un centre qui ne s'occuperait
que du médical pour elle le centre henri
lafay a changé sa vie des sorties des
deux parties c'est peu beaucoup
c'est pour nassimah dindar présidente du
conseil général
les difficultés des personnes porteuses
de handicap devrait être mieux reconnu
afin de sensibiliser les consciences et
de permettre aux personnes porteuses de
handicap de s'exprimer le 1er juin aura
lieu au jardin de l'état
la deuxième journée départementale pour
les personnes porteuses de handicap
l'opportunité pour tous de se retrouver
et d'échanger
c'est aussi pour les personnes porteuses
de handicap et leurs accompagnants
l'occasion de découvrir l'intégralité
des moyens mis en place par le conseil
général et ses partenaires deuxième
journée départementale en faveur des
personnes porteuses d'un handicap ou les
familles pour
découvrir les dispositifs que nous avons
mis en place pour accompagner ces
personnes porteuses de handicap
qu'il s'agisse du transport des places
dans les établissements
le pass loisirs le fasse transport mais
aussi les porteurs de handicap
il faut réaliser des choses formidables
et sportif
les association handisport toutes les
associations qui perçoivent des aides
donc une belle journée de rencontre
puisque le conseil général tout au long
de l'année nous accompagnons les trente
sept mille personnes porteuses de
handicap à la réunion pour un montant
très conséquent 75 millions d'euros
chaque année
il y a aujourd'hui à travailler mieux et
avec tellement le conseil général met en
place des moyens considérables pour
permettre au plus grand nombre possible
de personnes porteuses de handicap de se
sentir mieux dans notre société
ces personnes ont tout comme nous un
rôle à jouer dans notre société
anou d'éveiller nos consciences et de
participer à l'élaboration de la réunion
de demain une réunion qui n'exclura
personne et prendra en compte chaque
réunionnais
rendez vous le 1er juin porteurs de
handicap ou valide au jardin de l'état
le conseil général de la réunion vous a
présenté lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais